all right today's topic uh we have a
little throwback here we haven't seen
these boys in a minute straight from
Rumble the paradise of the defranchis
demonetized cuz some people made some
comments like oh myON you uh you know
you're gay we saw you uh with with your
white friend Eric and he kissed you or
you were on a bed with him blah blah
blah and it's like that's how I could
tell a lot of people didn't play sports
or weren't in the military or did
anything like uh with other men where
there's like a unified front or a goal
um anyone that's an athlete anyone that
is an former military anyone that was
any type of situation where uh you're
grinding it out with other guys in some
kind of competitive atmosphere that's
just how it is you guys don't understand
like how close you'll get with um with
guys that you suffer with okay that's
how you build real bonds that's how you
build uh that that uh Brotherly Love is
through unified struggle towards a
common goal and um and yeah I mean
anytime someone says some [__] like that
I'm like yeah that's how I know that you
weren't an athlete or you never did
anything uh with other uh competitive
guys yeah very sad story man uh nah bro
that's fruity only white people do the
fruity bonding
[__] that's how I could more than likely
bro you know what you're probably a neck
bearded Fat Bastard and you probably
never played Sports in your life you
were track and field that's an alone
sport you have any other Combat Sports
you train at MMA gym yall ever I train
in the gym I train at trar yall ever get
in bed
no no no kisses on the cheeks what about
comedy no one even no but the thing that
happened is that you guys are so afraid
of being gay or looking gay yes facts
you guys are so afraid I'm terrified
yeah I know you are you are you 100%
you're one of them I really don't care
about them pictures I don't care about
him being bothered I understand I
actually understand what he's saying
about whatever the kamarad it looks
weird but I'm not afraid of looking gay
I'm not afraid of looking in certain
ways you guys are so you don't mind if I
give you a kiss I'll tou you no cuz I
don't I don't I don't that's a that's a
that's a different stuff that's a
different thing what's different I don't
want people to invade my prophecy or
invade my my bubble that's a different
thing I will punch you in your mouth
because that's not the relationship that
we have and I don't want no kisses from
here but we are we a team we we Trav
that's not the relationship we have
sometimes we be in hotel rooms and
stuff
when
we I had you cuz we were we were you
some your girl against the world no no
okay so that's pretty much [__] like you
guys are afraid of that I don't give a
[__] I don't give two [__] and the thing
that it's not he's bothered about it
people have been I've been bullied in my
I've been bullied in my life I've been
say they said [__] to me so what how do
you fight back I don't give a
[__] no that's what you do okay I just
didn't know like you like I don't give a
[__] I really don't care I don't care
you called you called in about gay assur
you called in about them gay ass to
scream about
cartoons right now you talking it's like
six video it's six [__] photos of you
doing some gay [__] bro you only explain
two of them get out of here bro what are
you talking about [__] out here already
explained it multiple times you hugging
okay why are you a white boy from behind
when yours is on that [__] here why is
you letting a white boy kiss you on the
mouth with his eyes
closed what the [__] are you doing bro
if myON was as you say gay I would know
watch any NBA game watch any sport what
do they do when he does a good play they
slapped ass is that gay too [__] that's
the funny thing he wants to defend it so
much that's not gay but he's the hold on
he's going to be the first one to call
anything that is not gay gay you're
doing this you're doing this that's gay
you're doing that that's gay he say you
was gay for dancing it doesn't matter it
and that's the problem that I have like
I don't care that you look whatever you
guys are scared about that problem is
you're going to name oh boy you're going
to chill with girls that's gay you're
the one that's naming anything on the
calendar that's gay anything on the
[__] uh on earth that is not gay that
is gay and then when people are calling
you out on [__] that actually looks sus
you're like no it's cuz you're scared
but who who gives a [__] if you actually
really know who you are yeah and what
you're about yeah and who you actually
want to [__] that's you say B man that
[__] call me goofy look at you bro
you're
goofy Boogie is a homosexual bro you are
a
[__] I was like yo this guy called me
gay for Sala dcy with ladies I just
started laughing because I've heard it
before it doesn't bother but then I the
same person is like eating's gay I like
okay the same guy who advocates for not
living with your wife yo so you can live
with your Bros yo if you it's saying but
what is one thing they got they're good
at sucking what is one thing they're
good at sucking [__] even gay dudes got
the beat on that what
the I don't know I'm just assuming I'm
just assuming I don't know what I don't
know on personal experience I'm assuming
okay good like like the same person you
know what I'm saying who's out here like
literally in bed with other dudes I have
no problem with people wanting to
express themselves however they want
it's just when you hyper judgmental like
preach said and then your personal life
look a little funky so it's like maybe
you need to chill out on calling other
people homosexuals or gay or anything
like that that's it you're in no place
of saying that that thing looks gay like
that thing's a s or whatever what not
you're in bed with a dude I don't even
want to sit on this dude's bed you in
bed with a dude but you're calling
people get you're [__] up you telling
dudes not to live with wives so they can
live with their
Bros you know what I'm saying you tell
people it's gay to eat poom poom I'm
going to be honest with you bro I was in
the military for I never saw no [__]
like that now I'm not saying there not
people who do a little Slap Ass there's
very few but like sometimes people
listen there like one or two but they
never come on man Slap Ass yeah there's
like there's like always one or two
weirdos okay but it's not that common
but maybe I'm wrong maybe if you guys
are in the team or you guys played
sports or you were in the military or
maybe you do Combat Sports did y'all
ever lay in bed with other dudes and
then cuddle up did y'all ever kiss each
other on the cheek or grab him from
behind man maybe that's more common for
y'all so we want to hear from you guys
what is your perspective on
this there's one comment that made me
laugh though go ahead so he was getting
his face shaved by his homie right it's
a full shave that's fine just died
because someone said that could be a
barber I was like bro it's just a full
face
full you a just a full facial yeah you
don't you don't need a barber to fully
shave everything no you just put the
cream on put
the in the military used to always have
to be clean shaven I have never seen
someone be like yo let me let me let me
get that for
you he's dead he's literally he's dead
he's dead dead dead yo let me let me
get let me yo yo bro y
bro yeah no the miror don't do you
justice let me get that the miror don't
do you justice my [__] let me let me
let me let let me let me hook you up
yeah you looking
clean it's that I do not have a problem
with it we know you said it a million
times I'm going say it a million times
more but the more you say it the more
you say you got a problem with it yeah
just like he does I'm fine I'm fine like
just like he does just like he
does it's not listen it's not
what was that horse noise it's
not all listen I just want I it's not
good to me it's just funny the only
that's funny is just like it's the hyper
masculine alphal types who when you just
like peer behind the it's like are you
calling anybody gay when you got this in
your closet we just want to check in on
our boys on Rumble see how they do your
boys you're the one that keep bringing
them up you you're the one want to get
physical with him
what they proposed I didn't oppose